he got called out he got called out by
one of his ex-girlfriends saying that he
was abusive in the relationship
he's been canceled meaning what do you
know what cancel
culture is oh we're so now nobody's
gonna nobody
they basically you know what me too is
yeah but it's
it's it's um i was gonna say it's like
uh
what they call it where you you suddenly
everybody decides they're not going to
go to target
what do they call it when you um yeah
yeah yeah when you try to cancel when
you say that they've done
something wrong there's another name for
it that you would typically use it's um
it's where you're against that
target and you're not going to go there
anymore that kind of thing yeah yeah
what do they call that
it's called cancel culture well that's
what you're calling it because it's
that's the thing they call it now but
it's like your boycott
boycotting thank you kinda yeah yeah
like your boy yeah so it's like boy your
boy caught it
right so marilyn manson is being
boycotted right now or cancelled because
one of his ex-girlfriends said that he
was abusive in their sexual
life i love that any woman that says
anything you have to automatically
believe
anything she says yes exactly
you're [ __ ] if you don't right i think
a couple other women piled on after her
they always piled on right right yeah
like cosby so you you were like cosby
exactly you raped 50 women over the
course of 30 years
none of them ever came i thought it was
hundreds with cosby yeah i think it's
like
50 something like whatever but um it
could be more but
i'm saying you know that you did this
for
for the last 30 years this is what
you've done it none of them came forward
until one woman said something then they
all
rushed in right i was at a party with
him in 1979.
he drugged and raped me too really i
mean
that you know so how long did cosby how
how long was cosby in prison for he just
got out but how long was he in for do
you know i don't know four or five years
right no
no was it three three or four years
about three or four years right around
three or four yeah
so what do you know do you know the
actual like like
the story behind his case right now it's
a it was a civil case or a criminal case
it wasn't criminal right it was civil
well i mean it's great
it started it started civil it started
it started civil where basically
he this woman was suing him and
he decided he was going to settle the
lawsuit
and they settled because she said look
you gave me whatever it was
lsd or you gave me something you know
yeah
quaaludes and which kills me because
when they say it like this
we were at a party he drugged me he
raped me
yeah so his version of course is
we were at a party i was taking
quaaludes i asked her if she wanted some
she took some we ended up you know 30 45
minutes later we end up having sex
right so it's no different than we were
at a party
i was taking some xanax the chick i was
with said hey you got any for me and i
said absolutely here have one
45 minutes we ended up having sex in my
car you raped or you drugged and raped
her
like no different than i was having a
couple of drinks i said hey you want a
drink sure
she had a couple drinks shots at the
ball we ended up having sex in the in
the parking lot guess what you
dr you you drugged and raped her i mean
it's like that
progression so he ends up so he ends up
for the purposes of the
of the civil of the civil suit he says
um they said did you drug and you know
did you drug recovery
yes i i gave her the quaaludes we had
sex with this
i didn't rape her i did this i did this
i did drug her
i did have sex with her i did this i did
that and i'll say all this
provided you're never gonna be able to
use this it's not right of course of
course of course
then of course that she gets the
settlement everything goes through boom
let's put it out there
now let's we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to use that against you to
file criminal charges and we're going to
charge you and you're going to go to
prison and then
all these other women say you know what
time to get paid i was at a party with
this guy 20 years ago
he raped me too he and suddenly
everybody jumps on the bandwagon the
next thing you know this guy's
this guy's apparently been raping people
you know every few weeks for the last 30
or 40 years
and he's 80 something years old and he
ends up going to prison
and then of course the judge finally
looks at it and says well wait a second
you can't you first you can't use this
but on top of that
he's admitting to something for the
purposes of a lawsuit
for a civil civil lawsuit right like
he's like like civil lawsuits are all
about money they're all about getting a
settlement right
right a criminal lawsuit is actually for
prison time right because that's what
that's
that's the way you make it right like
that you and i get into an argument
or something and you cost me money
somehow you get me fired from my job you
do whatever you start
you slander me somehow and i get fired
and i lose my house
i turn around i sue you and then i
proved that that's true that what you
said was a lie
and you got me you know you got me fired
and i ended up losing my house i had to
start over well guess what now you owe
me money and that's how you do it
because i can't come over and club you
and i can't throw you in prison
right because it's civil it's not what
you did was wrong but it's not
illegal so you know you handle it
civilly and that's what they handled it
civilly we handled this civilly because
i we have a difference of opinion you're
saying i dropped and raped you i'm
saying we were at a party and we both
got [ __ ] up and we had sex
yeah you know it's a difference of
opinion but i don't obviously i'm bill
cosby i don't want this to go any
further i'm an 80 year old man you're
going to give you a couple million
dollars that's nothing to me
yeah but uh yeah so bill cosby going
back to bill cosby his
lawyer that he used was one of trump's
lawyers
he was uh one of the lawyers trump to
use for his impeachment
trial right uh i don't know
i'm not sure i'm pretty sure it was yeah
trump lawyer look at how quick that was
austin [ __ ]
trump lawyer bruce castor plays a
central role in the bill cosby going
free look at bill that's not bill
yeah it is that's [ __ ] bill he's a
[ __ ] white guy no that's his lawyer
that's bill's lawyer bruce
that's what i said bruce you said look
at bill get bill said look at bruce
you're all [ __ ] up today your words
are all
jumbled up run it back pal lawyer bruce
castor has now gotten
two extremely high profile americans off
this year
in a much-watched legal proceeding first
came president donald trump now comes
bill
cosby that's crazy so
um so what is the reason so bill
he when he went to prison for a few
years for this case
basically the judge who looked at this
said you can't take
this evidence you can't take the [ __ ]
that went down in the civil lawsuit
you can't take it to a federal you can't
take it to a criminal
transfer into a criminal lawsuit so it
goes against the rules
right well i mean he was just
he's saying that it's it's different
first of all well first of all i used it
we don't we all agree this cannot be
used you cannot you know this
this is for the sole purposes of this
trial blah blah blah
and then they end up and give it to the
uh so obviously rape is a very bad thing
you know it's not good to rate people
yeah especially when we can agree you
got hundreds of people
you got hundreds of women saying that
you raped them right like you should be
in [ __ ] prison if you're raping
hundreds of people
right but the re what he's saying is
there's also statute of limitations
you know what i'm saying so the statute
of limitations on almost all of them was
up
almost almost all of them but i love
that it's all up but they all get to
come in when you're sentenced they all
get to line up and talk
okay well wait a second her statue of
limitation she wasn't i didn't rape her
she said you did we're gonna let that
stand
let her come up right you know so they
get to go in and say you know oh in
1990. so are they saying they [ __ ] up
by like
it was [ __ ] up they should not you
locked them up yeah
no what theirs did was they said this
evidence could not have been
used and as a result of that i'm
throwing it out with
prejudice so you can't use it you can't
bring it back and i'm dismissing the
charges with prejudice you cannot re
re-charge him so the state can't come in
and say oh we're going to charge him
again and
without the evidence no the judge is
saying one you're not using it again two
you're not charging him again
right he's go home so here's the thing
what were you gonna say
so you don't think the whole time he's
going through his trial or whatever
his him and his lawyers have to know
like you can't be using this evidence
yeah right it's it's always subject i
mean
it's always subjective like and look
there's stuff where it's clearly you
cannot use this evidence right
and the u.s attorney will argue it your
honor but this
and sometimes the judge will well i'm
going to allow it and what are you
talking about like the defense will say
well
statute such and such says i disagree
and they'll
knowing that you understand that this is
going to
this will be appealed and it'll be
thrown out and the whole thing will be
thrown out but the judges know and the
u.s attorneys know they're like yeah i
know
but think about it it's gonna
the trial's this long by the time he
gets to prison by the time he
appeals it by the time he does this it's
two years
then even if he gets a new trial which
is probably pretty good
it's going to be six months before we
have to be the trial we'll delay it as
much as we can we'll get another three
years
he'll do three years before he gets back
in front of
a jury and he's already lost once so we
can probably negotiate with him during
that period of time to say look
immediate release but you have to plead
guilty
and most guys even if they're just gonna
say all right all right fine just let me
out let me know
like i'll be a felon i don't care just
let me out like they're so now
it's three years you're traumatized and
you see how the system works and you
realize how
stacked against you it is so you realize
right away
look i'll do anything just to escape the
situation
like i've got 20 years and you're gonna
let me out after three
i'll take it even though i haven't done
anything most of the time when they do
stuff like like the innocence project
comes in and stuff and they'll say
look turns out that all of this evidence
all this evidence that you have against
this guy
you said this is his blood you said this
is his fingerprints you said this he
said guess what not his blood not this
not that
most of the time the states will come in
and say we're going to retry them
what are you talking about your your
main evidence was the blood was the same
and it's not his it's 100 we we actually
have another person that it may be that
died in prison two years ago what are
you talking about they're like
no no we're gonna retry them we'll try
it again because they're they're like
look first of all the guy's
he's been locked up 10 years he knows
how bad it is he knows the
the chance that he got this over soon
yeah what he's innocent he's in prison
and the chance
he knows that this was a fluke so he
knows if we retry him there's a chance
he's going back he might still get found
guilty and we're going to use that
to try and get him to plead guilty so
that he can't
sue us for what we did to him right and
most guys will say
yeah okay i'll take it like wait you
didn't rape her you didn't rape and
murder that woman you didn't do this you
didn't do any of this it's all 100
uh true we can prove it now you're still
ready to sign something
and walk away why because i thought i
was going to die in prison and and i'm
just desperate to just get out
right you just want to get the [ __ ] out
right any you know for all i know i
could be i could be killed in here
before i walk out of here especially now
that people have seen me on the news
and they know i'm getting out a lot of
jealousy in prison people will attack
you for no reason
a lot of guys like won't tell people
when they're getting out
like a lot of guys will be like look
don't go around like the last month or
two saying yeah man i'm out of here in a
month i'm out of here in a month
because a lot of these guys aren't
getting out for 10 years some of these
guys are going to die in here
and you're walking around saying that
don't there's a lot of people that are
bipolar they'll flip out on you and
attack you
so don't say nothing so you know you
don't know what's going to happen these
guys are signing just to walk out the
door
of course once they're outside they turn
around they're like i should have sued i
should have this i shouldn't have signed
that paper i shouldn't
but you were under such duress right
plus was it wasn't part of the argument
that he's [ __ ] 80 years old like
letting this guy out even if he's a
rapist
he's nothing to worry about he's a
[ __ ] idiot he's not a risk he's right
he's not a risk he's not like a [ __ ]
30 year old
guy serial rapist because these women
aren't saying that he beat me
he beat up beat me bound me threw me in
the trunk this car drove me to
drove me out in the woods raped me and
left me for dead they're saying hey slip
me a mickey and
next thing you know he looked good and
he was a he's famous and rich so i had
sex with him
you know they're not saying he he beat
on me and hailed me down
and you know my eyes were black and blue
and my broke my nose and
you know